hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to unforgiving a northern is
now there's an indie horror game but it
actually looks very very good with fluid
animations and cool art styles and
supposedly something oh and furry am I
supposed to not be seeing anything here
[Music]
did I die I just got into this game I'd
rather not be dead oh hello no it's the
forest all over again
I've watched washed up on a beach oh no
oh God it's not shake powered must find
help so yeah this game it's an early
alpha so it's not actually done but from
what I saw it looked pretty damn good
for just being an alpha but did it Sarka
tell oh I can't see anything
hello is anyone on this abandoned Island
probably full of monsters that wants to
help me oh okay I can't all right so
just to set the mood Lulu [ __ ] god
damn it
flop all right just to set the mood a
little bit I'm going to not shout into
the forest randomly I have no idea where
I'm going I have no idea where I'm
supposed to be going I'm seeing like the
out lunch stuck there seems to believe
there's something like blocking out the
entirety of the moon which makes me
think that I'm next to a mountain of
some sort but if I can just get around
it
hi okay all right I'm sorry what was
that could you repeat it I don't give a
[ __ ] okay
all right thank you have a nice day hey
cool that was nice
does next way they do that thing where
they talk to me in my Oh light oh good
maybe this can reclaim a little bit of
my sanity here
hello I finally found a light oh good
matches finally how in the world yeah
shake everything you find it well so
many matches unlimited even right not a
set number hope whoa
all right then a giraffe got a bamboo
giraffe oh it's adorable
oh it's adorable oh it's got blood on it
oh that makes it twice as adorable oh
okay
all right it's got a deadly oh boy
conditions good a deadly is there any
reason I should drop the match other
than it's gonna burn my fingers I don't
even know where I came from
did I fall off of a boat I like see
another light over there okay that's a
good sign unless it's a very bad sign
because it's like leading me into the
trap of death I don't like that trap
that trip okay
so there's nothing here though but I
seem to be going right way question mark
okay okay okay didn't hear anything no
nothing happened
what are you guys talking about nothing
happened nothing happening no squeaky's
no squall goes nope I don't hear
anything
nothing nothing nothing no if I say it's
nothing it ain't nothing now I don't
hear nothing
know what I should toss this before it
burns the fingers I got everybody I'm
just going to sit here listening to the
whole nothing going on here oh I bet you
match out of a matchbook here all right
yeah going on my own way boy my stomach
is crumbly tonight it sound like big
bass drum hits oh oh oh you always
leading me into underground cavern mines
and whatnot
alright good thing I didn't have to
light any of these are the ways I was a
little strange
before at the hall okay now you're gonna
go quiet now you're gonna go quiet now
the game's gonna go quiet when I'm
already in the midst of the road to hell
gonna go quiet well I'm just gonna stand
here and perpetual darkness for just a
moment as a tree light a match I hate
this mechanic by the way it's very
terrifying I don't even get to beefy to
blow the matches up start off fudge oh
hey here good eye for a second there I
thought I wouldn't have been able to
keep going down into the depths of hell
yeah this is a good idea what part of
like sort of like coming off of a boat
accident or however the hell I got in do
you know and maybe I should just turn
back that'd be great
I could do that I wasn't a brave boy
please tell me this place isn't filled
with spiders
Oh oh good I can make these float in
midair that's nice awfully nice
don't know these do some kind of ruins
of some sort I like me a good room it's
not a naked streaker was that a streaker
was that a streaker in the middle of the
sky damn mine was there someone running
naked in this goddamn mine because
that's something that I will not stand
for okay put on my sneaking shoes too up
people okay don't you burn my fingers
off all right looks like that one lasted
a lot less long than the other ones that
I've had all right moving on who's
making okay come on I'm a nudist myself
so you can just depend on me that's up
something connecting to the internet
from the 1994 that was a good joke beans
Thanks at this point any clever and good
things on three
are going to lead to something like that
children singing in the dark
yes I'm gonna say to me you have some
hidden message that you want to tell me
little kid
[Music]
oh hi are you naked - oh I'm very naked
myself all right you're still there talk
to me what the [ __ ] is happening okay
hey oh hi oh yeah nice ass okay what you
bit me oh you're not gonna come here and
apologize no he's gonna walk up I'm
naked I don't care what is this what
kind underground mine is this why you
two have a dedicated railway system the
leading into nothing and are you just
trying to show off with your new - dear
[Music]
you know what I think I'm finding that
up I don't care
so how about you thank you with brings
and shove it oh oh oh hey oh god oh hi
oh boy
you too huh oh nice boo bite holy [ __ ]
oh no that what happens after you get
bid oh oh I thought that was like oh man
I thought that was just like time
they'll just the mattress went out on
its own
okay check my arm all my arm is not
looking good
Oh No I'm gonna turn into a tree babe oh
boy oh boy feel bad decide I just okay
it's bad huh don't let the in doll
daughter okay all right that's good
advice I don't know what you're trying
to tell me but you're pointing in the
direction holding out your hand I don't
know what that means but it's probably a
clue I'm just gonna keep all the tracks
cuz I don't think I can go anywhere to
the left and right it's just a solid
wall yep it's solid wall alright then
don't mind me gonna check my arm I'll
burn up at her your mom
it is white help I call the boat my
phone don't work what the hell's going
on I've got that disease from Game of
Thrones
hi oh no oh no oh god no ah this is
unpleasant if it was just an unpleasant
experience I'm gonna demand my money
back
good on the con in town-- okay yeah look
oh I'm not gonna sit through there are
you talking about yeah I can't fit
through there so there's any gonna
happen no God like the baby on fire oh
well I don't have a lot of time so you
know what I I'm sorry sorry about this
I'm sorry about this the most of you
mister I don't want to do it I don't
want to light your baby on fire are you
even alive I'm sorry
how you doing you know I was gonna get
to do what is there any other options it
is there is no other option I literally
can't there's no other way cuz I talked
to little girl over here I don't think
so I don't have a lot of time to debate
besides my arms getting worse it's
getting worse okay
I got it I got I'm sorry
Oh like the worst thing I could possibly
do Oh
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh that is unpleasant Tommy oh
where am I going
am I out I made it through all right can
I just turn into a tree and take my
punishment for this all right look you
head and fall women been to surprising
considering everything else oh I've made
it out oh I thought those bug their
heads on a spike
all right you know you can leave me
alone and also go [ __ ] yourself that be
nice too great
okay alright I'm gonna get help just
some time for them to see me turn into a
tree I don't want any oh hey oh my god
oh my god oh my god what was that I
didn't even see what it was okay
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ]
would step stepping all over this woods
these woods okay I don't like that don't
repeat that on me what okay he's gonna
assume that it's not following me just
kind of keep on keep swimming what I
shut it down this never should have come
to this island if this kept swimming oh
boy
oh what's this what's this I see let's
see
I'll sum the light okay alright then can
i light it No alright that's fine
end of the road what jump into the ocean
is that gonna help me god I see it over
there I'm not gonna be able to get oh
hey well that looks modern
doesn't matter I'm doing uh-huh I think
it's getting better you know I think I
think it's actually getting better
oh good a fan of My Little Pony lives
here cray rune Svendsen and Henrik
Andersen okay Rudy sacrifice rituals of
the old days oh my kind of people live
here okay really if they're in a
ritualistic sacrifice then hey
[Music]
all right then
hi uh my timing could use some you know
help oh boy don't mind me just gonna
wipe out this place ah okay all right
well the party came and went
[Music]
whoo-hoo okay that's aa good day sir
thanks for letting me use your home I'll
just take the back door all right I
don't know where I'm going but I the
funny feeling that I'm gonna meet
something in the woods very soon that's
gonna rip my entire body out of my ass
oh boy if you could just please when
it's turning me inside out be quick
about it you know try to make it a
painless you know that is an unforgiving
him indeed that has my own good it's
fine I'll walk it off
hey he's laughing hey stop laughing the
Joker's nuts gotten old okay
[Music]
so for those of you watching at home I
think I think we made it I say I think
everything's gonna be okay now oh I
don't have matches anymore Christmas of
rain that's good
couldn't see anything anyway Oh dad
that's illuminating thank you for that
yeah okay all right all right I'm
running oh it's right by me well when do
I go
cleaning sleep thank you for can you
please pick it up a knot thorn I need a
little more light here for goddamn it
for tea you're the god of thunder sword
to Tommy all right bye
[Music]
okay I am
I know it to be so I am just going to
say that this was really well done I
like that concept art by the way I'm
just a tree like that's how I turn out
to be that's my pose if I'm gonna turn
industry I'm gonna get a better postman
yeah I'm gonna get a pose like and I'm
gonna give pose like oh the worst puppet
in the world and here the world's
stupidest tree the fat of the dab only
lasted three years and yet here it
stands as a testament to its eternal
stupidness here we go this is me crying
forever with blood so that was
unforgiving in northern him this looks
really good it's got a lot of potential
here it really built up some creep
factor and I love the fact that for the
most time you didn't even get to see the
horrible monstrosity until right at the
end when it ran away from the crying
whatever it was it was just cool that
was really well done because it made it
terrifying cuz it's like I gotta keep
running I can't stop the look there's
ain't no two ways about if I look I'm
dead I'm not going for it and it built
that up really well and also had the
really intriguing and horrifying choice
of burning the baby of mom who's been
turned into a tree and that's gonna
happen to me and then some naked people
that just throws in for some fan service
but evenly that was pretty good so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this down the
comments below and also help get this
Greenland it doesn't cost anything you
just got to vote for it so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]